hey what's going on it's Bill Burr and
it's time for the Monday Morning podcast
for Monday August 14
2023 what's going on how are you
how's it going in your world
um oh Jesus
I am all vacationed out
I had a great time on the vacation the
vacation was too long
too [__] long
because we did my first Vineyard first
before we came to Massachusetts you know
and usually we just go to Massachusetts
but I went to Martha's Vineyard first
and you know and I was good after
Martha's figured but then after Martha's
Vineyard we went to Massachusetts in
case you weren't listening in the
beginning after Martha's Vineyard became
Massachusetts
and um
yeah
I I I'm and it was funny it's now now
I'm on the [__] road
you know
my family's back wished and I am [__]
still out here I did Springfield two
nights ago
which was amazing you know I uh
I hadn't been there in a couple of years
but like you know Springfield used to
just be sort of a really small city
except for the uh you know the
Basketball Hall of Fame was their their
big claim to fame and now
you know you couldn't miss it now it's
all buried there's all kinds of
buildings and stuff all built up or
whatever but I went out there I did the
show with Tony V
he absolutely murdered the night before
I was up at Giggles my clocks place
the the house that Lenny Clark built and
uh had a great time going up there
that's the greatest tag
in comedy for my money and
um
I went up there was it Friday to shake
the rust off
and uh then I went up to Springfield I
had a great show there and last night
you know we were in Halifax you're
supposed to fly up and come right back
and we got fogged in so we had to spend
the night there but it ended up being a
great thing because I got to walk around
the city a little bit this morning and
see how beautiful it is very underrated
you know a lot of people want to go to
Montreal I would say don't sleep on
Halifax
you know it's sort of like chill
Montreal there's not a zillion people
there and it's I don't know I think it
looked just as beautiful
and um
you know like
probably less expensive I would it's
kind of like Milwaukee versus Chicago
like you go to Chicago I mean just by
the time you get into Chicago after
sitting in that [__] traffic
you don't give a [__] anymore you're
just like that that was one of the worst
experiences of my life but then you know
right up the street you got Milwaukee
it's literally on the same Lake
you're looking at the same [__] water
with like half the traffic I know I've
said this a zillion times so I mean I
love you know both cities for different
like Chicago one I guess once you're in
it
and you're sort of walking around but
like uh
you know Chicago actually reminds me of
La where it's like it's a city but it
also in a lot of ways looks like a
suburb
you know
um
where LA but but you know it's not as
bad it's but like La looks like one
giant [__] suburb that never ends and
every once in a while there's a cluster
of buildings and you're like what the
[__] is that oh that's Century City
that's the Time Warner Center
that's the that's downtown Glendale
um and the rest of it is all like seems
like it's six stories high
um
all right
my [__] brain is all over the place
because we last night when we flew into
Halifax
um
you know it was one of these things it's
like I wanted to go home with my family
and they were just going like Well we'd
really love to have you up here then
they said listen we'll fly you up and
fly you right back
the same thing so I said all right [__]
it I'll do that fantastic so we ended up
flying up there and we're coming in on
Final Approach and
it was like
the the ceiling was it looked like it
was like 250 feet
came out of the clouds and uh they had
lost
um
one side of the cockpit as far as their
avionics whatever but you know they have
the backup system and then they have a
backup system to that I guess
as far as flying instrument which would
have been going back to the old days of
vors and [__] like that but um so we
landed
and you know with the idea that we were
going to fly right back
so I was working with Tony V
and Todd Parker the author
of billionaire Boogeyman
um
I'm trying to think the last time we all
did a [__] road to Gig together if we
ever did so we went up and had just a
[__] great time we show up all my
Canada gigs lately have been like
Outdoors
in like these parks and stuff and I'm
always going up going this is gonna
[__] this is gonna suck
you know because I I am like
institutionalized from when I was coming
up if you had an outdoor gig it was just
instantly like the best thing
that it could possibly be would be less
awful than some other outdoor gig but
the ones out in Canada have been
unbelievable so we show up
there's like [__] 10 000 people on a
hillside
you know
it's looking like Woodstock
and we were like what the [__] right so
I'm thinking are they gonna be as drunk
as they were in Calgary you know what I
mean oh no Calgary they were drunk when
I was indoors Outdoors it was during the
day
so they were actually a nice crowd I
don't know they all run together after a
while and uh
anyway they went up we went all went up
and the crowd was [__] amazing
everybody had a great set
and uh you know they let us smoke cigars
in the tent
backstage while we were waiting to go on
and it was one of those things like you
know
it looked [__]
big when you just looked at it but when
you walked out there on stage you're
like Jesus Christ
um and I had one of those sets where
I don't know I was just on so like I I
think I did like 10 minutes without even
getting into my ACT which is great
because that is the game
you know once you've been doing stand-up
for a while it's it's like how long can
I avoid my Act
and it's good
if you can because then
certain jokes you don't have the time to
tell so you get like a night off that
joke gets a night off and it doesn't get
all [__] used up you know it's like
Farmers they don't plant the same soil
every year you know they [__] switch
over so it's the joke version of that
not to get all John Cougar Mellencamp on
you you know
which is basically not being a farmer
and speaking for them
kidding I like what he does you know he
tried to fight the bankers didn't win
you know
was he John Cougar when that happened or
was it John Cougar Mellencamp
John Cougar then John Mellencamp then
John Cougar Mellencamp
I think that was
I think that's how it went
something like that you know I got a
buddy of mine like he he loves
you know you know like when you know
what bands
people are into
you know and when you find out that they
really love a band
and you and they don't know that you
know how much they love the band and
then what you do is you just start
trashing the band to someone else within
their earshot it's one of my favorite
things to do
like I knew this guy
I knew that he loved uh a couple of
these bands and one of the Bands came on
the radio
and I was just like oh gosh
I don't understand why so many people
like this band right and I see him perk
up and somebody goes you don't like them
I go dude Freddie Mercury is basically
gay meatloaf
laughs
which I obviously don't feel I was just
trying to get my body going right
because basically gay meatloaf it's it's
sort of
you know that sort of musical theater
angst you know
won't you find somebody love me
and once you love you know baby baby let
me sleep on it you know you know nerd
angst
are they just all you know that that
huffing and puffing and running around a
stage
you know in the most effeminate way ever
like I just you know I was just going
that route
like driving and this guy's because you
know I don't even understand like what
even your [__] Musical
like we don't line up at all like he he
finally figured it out that that's what
the [__] I was doing
[Laughter]
for the record
for the record I think Freddie Mercury
might be one of the greatest front men
of all time
but like as an AC DC fan like there's
some like I love Roger Taylor straight
across the board
all right but like you know
when it gets a little too too dramatic
like I I'll be honest with you I let's
there's a nice segment for you
um
like what is a band
or a song that everybody loves and you
just sit there and you feel like an
alien
you know at first you're like oh God I
[__] hate this song but then after a
while
when it just keeps coming on and every
time people just freak out and have this
emotional response after a while you get
past your hatred of this song and you
just start observing the people
because you're so tired of being the
only one who hates the song
that you actually want to just sort of
observe people enjoying it to try to
figure out what is it
that I'm missing
and for me the number one
example of that
for me
is that Queen song
Bohemian Rhapsody
I swear to God
I could [__] murder somebody when
that [__] song comes on
it's such a stupid [__] song it
doesn't make any sense I don't give a
[__] that it's difficult to sing
I see a silhouette
very very thin everywhere in the Box
what the [__] are we doing here
was it like a vocal warm-up that he just
put to [__] words I [__] hate that
song I hate that [__] song and it was
gonna go away but then they put it in
that [__] movie
um
that SNL movie what the [__] the name
of that movie
with Mike Myers and Dana Carvey
when Wayne and garth's
big adventure I can't remember it's not
[__] technical anyway
um they made that song like they brought
it back
from the [__] dead and uh and now
it's just like it's over like that's
literally like you know for the next
like 30 years
like [__] in the mood
that [__] song like you know I bet
somebody in 1940s was like [__] hated
that song in the mood
especially if he came back from war
you know
and he had PTSD you know
you're trying to block out all the
[__] horrors of war that you saw and
then there's just all these people dude
my dad but do bad but you but yeah
and you're just sitting there going I
swear to God if one more person
starts doing a funny walk pointing up at
the ceiling dancing to this [__] song
I am going to take some of my military
experience out on them
you know
um so mine is is is is that that
I hate that [__] song
um
and in defense of this I I love when
people hate songs that I love or hate a
group
like there's a kid Down The Comedy Store
that [__] hates AC DC and I just I
can't get enough of listening to him
trash AC DC because nobody really does
and he really hates them and he has such
passion for how much he hates him and I
just think it's the funniest [__]
thing
ever it was like in that Ginger Baker
documentary when he trashed John Bonham
like nobody trashes jump on him and out
of nowhere Ginger Baker just goes Joan
Bunn couldn't swing a sack of [__]
I almost fell out of my chair like oh my
God nobody trashes John Bonham there's a
clip at Keith Richards trashing them
like Keith Richards
doesn't like Led Zeppelin so much that
he didn't understand that Led Zeppelin
was a joke that Led Zeppelin was in on
the joke
it was like you know I think they were
talking to Keith Moon and when he told
him
um
you know when someone was telling them
the lineup of the band Keith jokingly
said like that's gonna go over like a
lead balloon
you know that old school expression like
you know
so they took that
and they just LED and they spelled it
differently and then instead of balloon
they said Zeppelin like that's that's
the legend anyway so Keith Richards
hated that band so much that like he
does he didn't even know that the band
was in on the joke
there's a clip of him going like yeah
Led Zeppelin and he goes because I never
got off the ground and he's kind of
making this ah you know what I'm saying
it's like yeah Keith that's the [__]
joke
so he was like low-key trashing them
and then he comments and he's like oh
and then that runaway locomotive on
drums
and every time I left that interview
because I always picture what if John
Bonham jammed with Keith Richards and
Bonham's doing his bottom [__] and just
keep looking over his shoulder like what
in the he's used to playing with Charlie
and look what [__] is this guy doing
anyway let's let's pick some other songs
you guys all know
that I hate that bom bom bom that song's
Sweet Caroline which was funny
they were playing that song before the
show last night
and what I loved about Halifax is when
it went to
they didn't do it like Nobody Does it
like that
maybe it's not even the song
wow that's it I never even looked like
that maybe I don't hate these songs I
hate the people that love them
you know when you go to a Red Sox game
and they start singing
Sweet Caroline and like you see like the
girlfriend you know like snuggling with
the boyfriend
and just watching I was sawing that
awful like completes them emotionally
somehow
or like do you remember like from back
in the day you'd be in a bar and that
stupid [__] song Mony Mony would come
on which is a good song
get [__]
see but what's great about these I
should love these songs because these
were the moments in my life
where I had the strongest feeling I
don't belong here
all right
like whatever is going on in this room
right now or at this baseball game or at
this nightclub I don't fit in here and I
always never felt quite like until I
went to a comedy club and I was like
these people are the same kind of
[__] weird that I am so all of these
songs I should love because I think that
they drove me
away from those people
I mean can you imagine living your life
and the people that you talk to
are the same people that when Sweet
Caroline comes on they they scream bump
bump bump
I mean how could you ever like
respect that person after that
maybe if you're a little I guess now
that they've been doing it so long that
kids grew up doing it and they did it
with their parents
or something
all right here's another one that drives
me up the wall that Alanis Morris sets
on it's like
are you ready
right and everybody goes you know the
smarmy thing to say is
she's not singing about
irony she's just talking about you know
some unfortunate things or some bad luck
that's not why I like that song
all right that's not what I mean that's
why I don't don't like that song
you know it because it just sounds
like someone that really has nothing to
complain about but is complaining and
whenever that song comes on
you know I feel like I'm sitting across
from her in like a restaurant
and while she's you know just bitching
about her life I'm just thinking like
why the [__] did I say I'd go out to
lunch
I should have just
like this is it
this is it I'm just gonna say I don't
want to do this anymore
okay I just can't you you [__] bring
up rain on your wedding day every time
we hang out and I just like
I think you need to go to therapy this
is something I think you need to talk to
somebody else about because I
am exhausted
hearing this
okay I mean this is life everybody has
like a bad day do you think you're like
special do you think that like bad
things aren't gonna
happen dude I'm sure I'm misinterpreting
this song but this is I'm just saying
like this is
my reaction
um
I don't get in too deep with this but
like
there's a lot of [__] songs like that
you know
this has to be a word for that you know
the Germans have a word that
scheidenfreude
I hope I'm saying that right which means
is is taking pleasure in somebody else's
misery or pain
there has to be a word for like
the hatred you have for people that like
bands that you don't like
full-on hatred it's whatever it is you
know that thing when you're just looking
at them
to the point they can almost feel your
look and be like you just feel your
energy like that's the level of Venom
that you have
as you watch people like you know
oh this listen there's a lot of I don't
there's a lot
I'm not going to get into it because
people like starting [__] so but there's
a lot of [__] that people think here's
here's one for you all right if they're
playing your favorite band
at the supermarket you know they're
probably not that good
although now that people get older and
stuff I've had you know I'll tell you
what's funny is anytime you walk into a
cool sneaker store
they're always playing uncensored
hip-hop is what I find and it's [__]
hilarious like you can't walk in there
with your kid
because some woman's gonna be rapping
about her [__] or somebody's gonna be
saying you know some guys you know
talking about his dick hanging out of
the Lamborghini
daddy that he owns you know
that is one of the more disappointing
things about hip-hop over the last I
don't know how long is people did it's
like I get it you you own a lot of nice
things
okay
oh is that right do you have one of
those is it made out of gold
um
well that's going to be impressive until
until you try to resell it
oh did you take all the millions you
made and and get
your face made out of diamonds
it was the funniest [__] ever
um
I feel like that's the the updated
version of like back in the day when
they would show some old rich white guy
and he would be lighting a cigar with a
hundred dollar bill
um I feel like the modern version of
that
is if you get a big Jesus Piece but
rather than it being Jesus it's you and
your your face are made out of diamonds
I should do that for myself
you know it's funny I'm such a weird
looking bastard like none of them would
really be precious stones they would be
all be on the lower
you know
like rubies
for my [__] red beard
like no one you know
you want to see your girlfriend be
underwhelmed get her a ruby ring
what kind of stone is that that's a ruby
isn't that like Russian money no that's
a Ruble that's a ruby
isn't he the guy who killed Oswald
um anyway I don't have no idea what I'm
talking about but anyway we ended up
staying
an extra day in uh Halifax and uh
I ended up
finding out they have incredible coffee
there let me give a shout out to the
place I went to the uh jeez where is it
here
into the camera into the camera we go
where is it I went to weird Harbor
Espresso Bar
oh I got my usual order a double
espresso and a flat white
with whole milk
outstanding
outstanding and quick
usually
when it's outstanding coffee
you usually have to wait a little bit
you know which is part of the fun
like look at them
he's a scientist you know look how much
she gives a [__] look at the technique
you know you get all into it oh in
Springfield you know what they got me
they got me one of those little [__]
Italian coffee makers
and they got me this coffee of I don't
have it with me here but uh it was the
best Smelling Coffee I've ever I think
I've ever smelled and it was already
ground up and those little Italian
coffee makers is you fill up the bottom
with water
you unscrew the thing right it looks
like a little [__] It's a combination
of like a teapot and a lantern is what
it looks like and what's great too is
the one that got me is the color
of the Italian flag right
which I feel makes makes you
subconsciously think the coffee tastes
even better because everybody knows okay
when it comes to Cuisine I mean there's
the Italians and there really is
everybody else
okay people have come close or whatever
did we ever do this do we have a ranked
cuisine
okay I would go
Italian
is is like you know there's no debate
okay there's no Jordan or Kobe it's like
no Italian food bam done go [__]
yourself like if there was one type of
food that I had to eat for the rest of
my life
okay there's no way I'm giving up pasta
pizza
you know all those all the fish the way
the way they prepare [__] everything
I'd go back to drinking
you know
having wine and [__] right
I would say they're number one
and then
number two is
for me it's a three-way tie
which would be French
Japanese
and Middle Eastern food
no you know what
it's too difficult because what I'm
gonna leave Indian food out of there
you know I'm gonna just ignore the
dumplings
that I had in Hong Kong you can't do it
you know what I can only do number one
and other than that I wouldn't argue
with anybody's uh
I wouldn't argue with anybody's number
two
but um
I will say the ones if it was like the
Premier League
what I love about the Premier League and
soccer is if you suck like you don't get
to hang around if you're at the bottom
of the league you're out of the league
and then they give somebody else a shot
I would say
German and English food
you know maybe I just don't know where
to go because I'm going to Germany
right and we went around that country
last time I was there we did cologne
Frankfurt
and Berlin
and everywhere I was I try what is that
[__]
what is that famous
versy was getting it everywhere we went
it's funny Kenny kept getting the
pretzels
and um ah
escaping now
German cuisine here we go hang on a
second German cuisine what the [__] do
you call that thing
German cuisine dishes
what do we got here
traditional German or maybe there's 20
of them I had no idea they had that kind
of thing here all right the big long
stupid [__] [__] they always have
to do every single time every [__]
time
you go to one of these Foods by you know
food sites it's always like well they
can't just list the [__] 20.
It's gotta be well you know Germany did
start two world wars and blah blah blah
but you know they make a great [__]
bratwurst bratwurst
all right I'm not gonna lie to you I do
like bratwurst I also like a German
breakfast too
I like how they put the hard-boiled egg
up like like it looks like a trophy like
you feel like you won something oh
schnitzel
there's a breaded cutlet is that pork
it's a chicken
schnitzel is a thin piece of meat
pounded into a flat style it could be
anything
all right the Schnitzel I didn't know
where to go
a Breslin which is a pretzel
oh look at this braised cabbage
I'm not gonna lie to you that gets my
[__] Irish blood going here very
popular German food the most combined
cabbage with broth and vegetable
Labs gas what the [__] it's a beef dish
German Sailors in the 18th century
develop it
because of limited resources probably
and it became popular amongst many
people on the land try making you I
don't even know what that is
all right but we schnitzel
um
to get the wiener schnitzel you gotta
have a little apple sauce or something
on the side it's a nice little [__]
back and forth there right I don't know
what I'm talking about I think I'm
hosting a cooking show at this point let
me do um
let me do some of the reeds
some of the Reeds where am I going of
course I clicked the wrong one of course
I'm not prepared this is what you guys
expect don't you
don't you
um all right where are we going here
great emails oh
look who it is everybody it's sole zip
recruiter
you know people if you're hiring you
know that it's incredibly hard to
attract top talent and with the current
labor market conditions it's even harder
than ever well especially when people
don't want to pay people to work
sorry uh oh shout out to UPS drivers
getting a raise because they're in a
union all right unions need to come back
[__] these [__] guys is it true that
that [__] that turned Twitter into X
for whatever reason it wants us all to
be microchipped is there a [__]
reason we're listening to this nerd
he's a [__] nerd with hair plugs and
a plastic face
now anyway
um that's why you want to partner
a partner who gets it zip recruiter
zip recruiter knows how tough it is
right now but they figured out solutions
for the problem you're facing see for
yourself right now you can try them for
free at ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter is ready to tackle your
recruiting challenges
um to search more of the right people
zip yeah
um post your job to 100 plus job sites
need to hire ASAP zipper recruiter smart
technology finds great matches for your
job sooner want first dibs on Talent zip
yeah
um let you invite the most qualified
people to apply to your job zip
recruiters pricing is straightforward no
surprise cause team up with a hiring
partner who understands what you need
four to five employers who post on the
site get a quality candidate within the
first day just go to this exclusive app
web address to try uh try it for free
ziprecruiter.com again that's zip
the smartest way to hire is that all I
had
all I need is just a little more time
okay I guess that's all I have okay well
with that we are in
we're into the reach all right wait
overrated underrated
all right what is an overrated like what
what's a [__] kind of food that
everybody loves
and like
you're just sitting there go I I just
don't understand this
you know there's a few this is there's
some weird ones out there
corn dogs
like Joe bartnick loves a corn dog and
I'm just looking at it like there is so
many things wrong
with all of that like it's so wrong like
they put it on a stick almost as though
they don't want the food to come in
contact with your body
um that is a pretty good is that a good
thing if if the food is on a stick
you should probably stay away from it
ice cream popsicles corn dogs
skewers are okay
but I'd say a stick
okay all right Bill let's just keep
moving on here all right oh
by the way
by the way uh
I tried out a couple of uh Pizza spots
when I was in Boston I went I was in
Weymouth I went to DeVry Gardens
um I give that five freckled thumbs up
[__] delicious food it's been around
since 1933.
amazing Decor a couple of townies up at
the bar
I had a great time over there man
Fantastic Pizza and I brought it back
to the house
you know it's funny and everybody's just
going like oh wait what's this place you
know because everybody has their you
know
it's really like it's like sports teams
back here that if you [__] go to the
wrong pizza place
um
but everybody loved it and then I also
went to the Marblehead House of Pizza I
did a North Shore I did a South Shore
uh Marblehead uh was a little thicker
crust and a sweeter sauce if you're into
that big [__] crush it really enjoyed
that and that's another one what I liked
about both of them is they look like
they had both been there for a long
[__] time that's usually a good sign
you know
like in the Marblehead House of Pizza
there's just this random banister
that splits like you walk up like two
steps
so that indicates that there's some sort
of insane line there if you come you
come wrong time so that was a good sign
too so
um
check those things up all right and with
that
first one just says Lobster
all right you can make fun of how I look
in the sun are we talking about the
crustacean dear Bill I just listened to
you I listened to your podcast from
yesterday you spoke about not eating
lobster because you didn't like them
being boiled alive
um did you know that Julia Child's the
first
celebrity chef did you know that Julia
Child's husband Paul didn't like it
either
he devised a method oh I guess the way
he did uh the the fact that the lobsters
boiled the life he said
this guy says uh he devised the method
of putting the lobsters in a bag
hanging hanging it over the kitchen door
he would bang them against the door to
put them into shock
so they didn't slowly boil to death
Jesus Christ
I mean the whole thing is like
that movie Casino which I absolutely
love but the level of violence in that
movie I mean
I feel like
now you've added like when they got that
guy's head in the vice
and then you're gonna boil them to death
at least even then he said put him out
of his misery
anyway it is an improvement and you
never know how the lobster is prepared
wherever you go I'm just saying there's
there is a better way and it has access
existed for about 50 years well dude I
need a little more details
he devised a method of putting the
lobsters in a bag and hanging them over
the kitchen door he would bang them
against the kitchen door to put them
into shocks so they didn't slowly boil
the death
well how many [__] times
I don't understand why they don't just
make like a little knife
and you could just really quickly like
to go back to Scorsese
the way the way they killed the guy Mori
he was in the middle of a story and he
just stuck the ice pick in the back of
his head oh and that was it
thought he'd never shut the [__] up
right why don't they just do that
you know what's so amazing about that is
how they all got in the car and then he
just kills him before they go anyway and
then they all immediately get out
fingerprints all over the place
but it did have the desired dramatic
effect
of how much eliminating somebody was
just like a day at work
um well I appreciate that anybody else
have a way
of quickly killing a lobster painlessly
and then you can boil them and enjoy him
on a lobster roll
all right um I can't believe this is
really happening bill
once again I can't believe this is
actually happening cameras are being
installed across London residential
neighborhood as part of the mayor
Sadiq Khan u-l-e-z ultra low emission
Zone
the plan to charge drivers every single
time they drive
we will be charged 12 pounds every time
we drive in any area of London unless
their car is electric or meets certain
admission standards
well here's the thing well let's say
everybody then goes out and buys the
electric car
or they meet these certain emission
standards
there's no way that they're going to
give up
on charging you 12 pounds every time you
drive they'll come up with another
[__] reason
once once those taxes or whatever
go into place
uh you're done I'll tell you what's
funny I saw this thing I'll read the
Restless in a minute um
I saw this Instagram video
and it said back before electric cars
um
they were oh wait let me find the
[__] video what the hell is it
because I want to quote it
I don't want to misquote this [__]
thing because they sent it to Dean Del
Rey because I knew he'd get a [__]
kick out of it
um where is it why won't you load why
won't you load wait I have an advantage
mode
vanish mode what
then they always says what you do is
swipe up from the bottom
seen a message what come on you [__]
[__] I hate these [__] goddamn things
how the [__] did he go into vanish mode
and every single time
there we go all right it did it okay
okay it says before all the electric
[__]
right we had and it goes back to like a
1970s Chevelle
it's like these [__] people they just
rewrite history and they don't even know
it that's not what you had before all
the electric [__]
okay first of all when cars first came
out they had electric cars way back 100
years ago and then secondly this [__]
guy goes from 2023 to 1970 and
conveniently
conveniently skips over the catalytic
converter conveniently forgets the Chevy
Chevette the Ford Escort the Dodge opal
remember all those [__] [__] cars the
Ford Fairmont the Mercury Zephyr
okay the electric car did not kill the
muscle car
[__] unbelievable and then not to
mention we're in a muscle car era right
now it's you can still buy a [__]
Hellcat
bad before the electric car [__]
it's like what is [__]
about an electric car
I just don't understand what is [__]
about it and for some reason a gas
combustion engine which the desire for
all of that has led us into a 20-year
illegal war that has bankrupted the
[__] country okay I'm not saying we
don't have oil here that we can't use or
whatever but let's not [__]
romanticize one [__] up way of
traveling to another [__] up way of
traveling because electric cars aren't
great either if you read about how
whatever [__] the natural resource
thing is they have they're in the Congo
okay and rather than just treating the
people you know nicely they have them
handling it without any gloves they got
pregnant women down there they don't pay
them [__] because these corporate [__]
don't want to pay anybody
and then what they say is well if we
didn't treat him that way then you know
they'd be [__] uh it'd be like 9
million dollars per gallon it's like or
you could take less of a salary
okay and I'll tell you that's what
really burns my freckled buns
because all they do is they talk about
individuals that are in the public eye
they hold them accountable and then
these [__] [__] are smart enough
to remain anonymous and to pay off
um politicians so they never get called
on their [__] so anyway people do
not buy into this [__] crap
that electric cars are better than gas
combustion or gas combustion is better
than the electric car
you know
that's also that other thing like you
know I saw this other video on Instagram
where this
this [__] guy's sitting there you can
tell he's tired
or whatever and he's sitting there with
his girlfriend this does you see this
truck stops in front of them there's
some Latino country and it backs up a
little bit then all of a sudden this guy
jumps out and he has a gun pointed at
both of them
and another guy opens the door and asks
for the guy's watch and I guess his wife
was saying step on the gas step on the
gas step on the gas and the guy didn't
he gave up his watch and then they took
off and then this guy writes sadly this
is the state of men being raised today
that oh this is the state of men being
raised today and I want to write yeah it
there they're commenting on [__]
Instagram videos about some Macho [__]
that they would have done
it's like the guy has a gun
pointed at you
this isn't The Bourne Identity you just
don't hit the gas and you drive over
them you hit the gas he squeezes off two
shots
and if you're not dead you're paralyzed
from the checks chest down over a Timex
watch
all right the guy let down his guard he
didn't have situational awareness the
time to get the [__] out of there is
when he if is if he could have noticed
the truck stopping and backing up that's
when you hit the gas once the gun's out
unless you know beyond a shadow of a
doubt the guy plans on killing you
if you're just getting that Vibe the guy
was standing
in front of the [__] car there's no
way for you to get the the gun
and if you think your foot coming off
the brake and stomping on the gas is
going to move faster than a bullet I
mean I can't help you
I mean there's a chance
the gun misfires there's a chance the
guy misses he's going to get at least
one round off
I don't know
and what if you run that guy over and
then those other two guys the guy who we
wanted you to watch and the people in
the truck are so [__] pissed
and now they're going after you and they
have guns
and you don't you have your car and your
Timex watch and your [__] chick who's
screaming like a [__] banshee
um
exactly this is the state I love one of
the people right there this is how men
are being raised it's like Yeah by us
you know I don't know
anyway what the [__] was I even talking
about here
where the [__] is it I was reading
something wasn't I oh anyway let's get
back to the 12 pounds every time you
drive a car our government will not use
this hyper surveillance responsibly of
course they won't and there everybody
has a side deal by the way just always
know that and then doing it during a
time when everyone is worried about
petrol and egg prices to feed their
families and they don't have time to pay
attention when you next come to London
please use that mouth of yours to blast
our immersion our emerging dystopia the
way you did our food thanks
um
yeah I don't understand like
I don't understand what we're headed
towards where they still feel they just
can't be watching us enough they can't
be listening to us enough and why things
like this
you know you know what they do they
always attach it to something good well
there's global warming this is stuff
that we have to worry about but there's
always that and then
you know which is obviously right
you know I don't find these videos funny
that people are making like you know
this is this is you know walking to your
car in Texas it's terrifying
it's been like 110 degrees for 19
straight days in [__] Arizona that
[__] is [__] terrifying and these
[__] are not talking about it they're
actually going to look at it as a way to
earn money
um you know there's part of me now that
they're gradually starting to talk about
aliens and [__]
there's a part of me that thinks
that what if there's a group of people
that are just like
like they have the technology to keep
them alive forever
right and what they do is they just
spend a couple billion years at each
Earth
and that's why because I always sit
there going like don't these sociopath
lunatics that are driving us towards the
end here aren't they worried that
they're also on this planet where the
[__] they're going to go maybe they just
leave
and there's an infinite amount of
Earth's I guess according to [__] that
I've seen on social media which really
doesn't mean anything maybe that's what
they're doing so they're not worried
about using up everything and
and then they just leave us behind and
we thought we were all so important
living our best lives and being social
justice Warriors and shooting tin cans
with your AK-47 you're just really
um
you're like a disposable like [__]
like toothbrush or some [__] to them all
right how to handle being laid off oh
brother
this is something I think a lot of
people
dear Bill I'm a 27 year old software
engineer
and I was just laid off now I would
think that that was pretty Recession
Proof
laid off from my first job and only
first and only job I have had since
graduating college five years ago I'm
looking for advice on what to do next
well I would stay in computers that
seems like you would always have a job
the person says I luckily have a good
support network of family and friends
that can take care of me for a while
until I get back on my feet but how
would you suggest I handle the next few
months should I start getting ready for
interviews immediately should I take
this time and travel
oh dude you got money if this is what
you're asking should I hit the gym six
days a week struggle to organize these
ideas and would like your thoughts on
this being a fan since I was in high
school and would love it if you made a
trip to Chattanooga Tennessee I love
Chattanooga
um only been there once and I had a
great time
um this is what I would do
I would figure out what I wanted to do
in life for a job if you like software
engineering I would
um
I would continue in that field I
wouldn't take too much time off because
they'd be like well what the [__] you
been doing
um but I will say that no matter what
job you get
um don't be living week to week if you
can
all right
um
the way the money game works is you
gotta like live
well beneath your means
and you just keep banking this [__] for
ability to survive times like getting
laid off and
for the ability if you realize that you
don't like what it is that you're doing
you have enough put away
that you can start getting like what you
want to be doing
um going
like when I
got into stand-up comedy there was
a time where I could have quit my day
job
um
but I didn't I kept working my day job
and as much I was so [__] enamored
with comedians that didn't have a day
job and how every day they could get up
whenever the [__] they wanted to because
that was my idea of it I didn't
understand that like
no when you quit your day job you've now
left the Matrix and it's as awesome as
it is it's slightly terrifying because
now
um
you're the one that has to turn the
wheel every day and you can very easily
just waste years and years a decade of
your career just being a lazy
[__] just not doing anything all day
and then just going out and
doing you said not really working on
your act trying to bang chicks or
whatever you're into and [__] go out
and go drink smoke some weed and next
thing you know
you're like this 40 year old comic going
what I should have been working right so
anyway I didn't quit my day job
um what I did was I treated stand up
from day one as like I had two jobs and
I just banked
as much money as I could I was still
living at home with my parents so I
didn't have any rent I drove a [__]
[__] my truck was paid off and it was
rusting out I didn't give a [__]
the engine died and rather than buy a
new car I just put a new engine in it so
it only cost me like it was like 1500
bucks at the time this is 30 years ago
as opposed to 15 grand for a new like I
kept my cost down
and
you know I paid for my own college
education so I had a bunch of debt I
paid that off
and
I did not quit my day job until I moved
down to New York and when I moved to New
York I had enough money
in the bank
to make my rent and then
hopefully you know that was the race
am I going to get into clubs and get in
with these Bookers and have enough Road
dates the way I did in Boston
that I'll be able to make my rent and be
a comedian before I run out of money
that was kind of the thing so it seems
to me even though he said he had a
support system that you were saving your
money so
I know this is a long answer but like
nobody ever really talks to you about
how [__] important it is to save
money
and you're certainly not going to learn
how to save money by going on to social
media because all people are doing is
trying to show these [__]
ridiculously glamorous Lifestyles that
they have it's kind of like that joke I
was doing
you know I was riffing I ripped that
idea
um
about this whole stupid ice bath
phenomenon you already have a bathtub
you can go to 7-Eleven and buy a bag of
ice why do you have to buy the super
like Sleek Europe so whenever I want to
take an iceberg and that's nothing too
like you've lived your whole [__]
life without taking an ice bath
okay and you're fine
so like everybody has like like this is
the [__] thing to remember like
remember kale
like out of nowhere everyone just
started talking about kale this is
they're just all these things are
are just these marketing [__]
[__] ideas to separate you from your
hard-earned money
okay and when you stop playing the game
is when the [__] you get ahead
okay don't look at all of these [__]
jerk-offs walking around with jewelry
and cars and and all of this [__]
crap okay first of all
you know
all they're doing like if you go around
and you flash your money like that you
are going to attract
some of the worst human beings you could
possibly make meet both male and female
all right what you want to be doing is
be that person that's [__] crushing
it and people don't even know it you
know Barry Sanders greatest running back
of all time as far as like
elusiveness and and whatever right and
only play 10 years and still almost had
the most yards of anybody other than
Emmett Smith I believe
that [__] dude
what was like [__] Jimi Hendrix
playing football it's like just just
doing [__] you'd never seen before
and he scores a touchdown and what would
he do he would just hand the ball to the
referee
okay look at how he conducted himself
after he scored a touchdown and apply
that to money
and then look at these other people that
scored touchdowns and rip open their
Jersey like their [__] Superman or
[__] spin around and do a backflip
and all of that [__] [__] that's that
guy flashing his [__] money I'm not
trashing Cam Newton by the way I'm just
it's the first thing I thought of
um
I'm just saying like
like don't I mean you could be in your
20s in our in already be drowning in
[__] credit card debt and you haven't
even gotten married yet you haven't even
had kids yet and all of this [__] and
you're gonna spend your whole [__]
life
chasing it or you could it's critical as
a young person financially
to
to start marching in the direction of
Financial Freedom
or nobody's 100 free because of where
these [__] Banker [__] have
everything set up that if God forbid you
stop
you know I told you I watched that thing
about that guy living off the grid
and you would think like holy [__] he
has to grow his own food he has to do
all of this stuff he must be just
exhausted every day he has he has more
[__] free time
you know like this whole
thing that they built is just designed
for you
uh I don't know something's going on
though right now I feel like we're at
the end of capitalism where for the
longest time Pete we've kind of looked
the other way at the level of greed at
the top and these guys where they just
cannot make enough money and they've run
out of ways to do it and now their only
way to keep making more and more each
quarter at this point is they have to
entirely eliminate the [__] middle
class and we all and it's it's going to
turn into like these places I would go
to like when I went to India where it
was like you either had money or you
didn't it's going to become something
like that
um
but the Brilliance is if you talk about
having a middle class now I believe that
they'll probably brand that as Socialism
or communism
um which why I feel like the best news I
saw this week was UPS the union of the
UPS drivers got the drivers a [__]
race because I used to be in warehousing
and those guys like they work on like
dogs so anyway I know I just went on a
whole [__] tangent I didn't even
answer your [__] question now that
I'm thinking about it but like I would
say
you know
if you need to take a little bit of time
off I wouldn't take much more than a
month off
I would try to get back into it as long
as if that's is what it as long as that
that is what you want to do
um
but I don't think going to the gym is a
bad idea
you know you might want to use this time
rather than you know travel hit the gym
do all this [__] you might want to just
have some quiet time
and go sit in the park and kind of think
about things and maybe try you know
sometimes when you get quiet you kind of
figure some [__] out kind of talking to
myself instead of you but
um that's one way to do it but uh sorry
you got laid off I hope that works out
but like I do like the fact
that you actually
um
can be laid off and you have some sort
of system set up where people are gonna
be able to help you out and it seems
like you're not too concerned about
money which means you're probably smart
with your money so keep doing that
and if you've been done with your money
uh start being smart with it dig
yourself out
you don't need to get an ice bath all
right all right was I wrong
you don't need to buy Christmas presents
just sit down with the woman in your
life oh God and have a logical
conversation but why are we giving into
this dumb [__] it's Jesus's birthday
can't we just sing Happy Birthday to
Jesus and our on our Christmas present
be no added credit card debt
we have food we have clothes we have
shelter we don't need anything else all
right okay
was I wrong dear Billy redface I am a
long time listener and a big fan of your
podcast and comedy specials thank you I
would like your opinion on an incident
that I had last week last week I had a
confrontation at a gas station
the dangerous place guy sprays you with
cat gas and flicks his [__] lighter
right yeah that's it I drive a Ford
Expedition and was waiting in line
all the pumps were in use dude there's a
lot of [__] fights
at gas station pumps there's a lot I'm
already thinking like the person that
like [__] starts pumping the gas and
then walks into the convenience store
and takes a [__]
you know half hour to come back out or
the person that doesn't pull all the way
up and then you can't drive around them
a lot of [__] fights there all right
all the pumps were in use one pump
opened up and this older lady pulled in
front of me and took the pump she got
out of the car and stared at me as she
walked to the pump oh she had a walking
boot on needless to say I was pissed
minute later the pump next to her opened
up
I pulled my big ass Ford Expedition into
this pump and made sure that I was
parked a few inches from her driver door
so that she couldn't get back in ah
oh my God
oh do I [__] love that
I mean that's that is fantastic
dare I say that that just made my
morning afternoon I'm a little late
today
um I started pumping the gas and
eventually
she walked over to me and said I can't
get in my vehicle
I replied with okay I was waiting for
that pump
she said well I thought you were waiting
for someone inside
you are a real gentleman thank you
was she saying that sarcastically I
finished pumping my pumping gas and
pulled away from the pump
and as I pulled away she took a picture
of my license plate
well what is she gonna do you can't get
a ticket for being an [__]
nothing has happened in my vehicle so I
don't think she did anything with that
picture she's just trying to scare you
given the fact that she was an older
lady in a walking boot do you think I
overreacted
I would like to hear your opinion on
this incident on your podcast thanks and
go [__] yourself well first the fact
that you don't feel 100 in the right and
you actually kind of felt bad when you
left
um you know what I gotta be honest with
you I wasn't there I would have to see
when she was staring at you I'd have to
see what that look was was she really
staring at you
was she just sort of squinting was she
nervous that you were gonna you know
what if your foot went off to break it
under the gas and she's old and has a
a busted foot I mean I don't know the
way you painted the picture I mean I was
all aboard on that um
look you didn't hurt her
you just you know inconvenienced her the
way she inconvenienced you I thought you
did it in a brilliant way uh I'm gonna
give a thumbs up on that you know
I mean personally I don't really [__]
with old people
uh
but uh I am not gonna lie to you I would
be calling her an old [__] [__] under
my breath but I wouldn't say that to her
so
whatever I think you did what you did
was brilliant God bless you it's [__]
hilarious uh incoherent idioms
uh dear Silly Billy sourpuss
we've heard we've all heard the term
card shark
generally denoting someone who is good
at cars well apparently
the original saying is card Sharp
but it's been set incorrectly for so
long and by so many people that the
incorrect
phrasing stuck and is now accepted
as correct
yeah because if someone in business is a
shark
you know depending on if you're hiring
them
you'd like it but if you're going up
against them you don't like it card
Sharp s-h-a-r-p
uh dude there's literally a game show
card sharks when I was growing up uh I
learned the original phrasing while
listening to the podcast of your fellow
Ginger comedian and mass native Conan
O'Brien one of my favorite people ever
who made a point to stress the P when he
said card shark
he's such a nerd I bet he says tow your
mark instead of on your mark
is he a nerd or does he just make you
feel a certain way because he's saying
things correctly
um
well I learned something he's a card
Sharp
it's card shark it's actually well at
this point now I feel if you say card
sharp you're actually kind of a douche
because you're using it as a way
I guess to correct people but who
doesn't love correcting people miss one
you know there's a way to do it
like this is a rule I have like I I like
if someone's a stranger I'm never gonna
correct if they mispronounce the word
because that's like you're setting
yourself up for a fight
excuse me it's actually card sharp I
mean
if you get punched in the face at that
point well you know
what did I think was gonna happen
um
anyway
this podcast is late so I'm gonna wrap
it up here thank you guys everybody who
came out in Halifax thank you
Springfield for the hospitality they had
a little [__] record player
with Led Zeppelin one on it good times
bad times I was listening to I was
drinking that delicious oh I didn't
finish it so it's like a three-tiered
thing looks like a lighthouse right you
put the water in the bottom and then you
put the coffee already ground up in the
middle and then you heat it up
and then I didn't understand this at
first because I was trying to pour it
out I'm like where the [__] does it go
you wait till the water bubbles up
it boils you put it on like I just put
it on top of the stove it heats up it
goes through the coffee and then there's
a spout and then it gradually fills up
the container up top and it is fantastic
all right that's it go [__] yourselves
and I'll check in on you on Thursday